good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now board and I'll take you back 15
years to 1996 when the law now boards
such as it was then met in Colorado to
think about building a 10,000 year clock
and a guest there was a young man who
came up with the idea for a building for
this 10,000 year clock was it quite an
elegant spiral you could go up and then
come all the way down without turning
around and it was so elegant we were so
impressed by the design by this trained
industrial designer that we hired him as
the first employee of the long now
foundation and that was Alexander rose I
think he was the only employee for quite
a while and then we checked with various
of our friends artists and such what do
you think of this building for this
10,000 year clock and laurie anderson
said looks pretty male for me and we
were chagrined but then we also started
thinking about buildings lasting 10,000
years and you do a little research and
there's not any buildings in that
category basically but we really wanted
to have a space for the clock that would
last a long time and we started to
realize that the research was showing us
that space is underground things that
are buried last for a long time but we
sort of hated the idea of just making a
basement for a clock filled water and
it's kind of a downer so then came the
idea of putting it underground only in a
mountain we figured that would satisfy
Laurie it would be a womb with a view
we can work with them
and then it also started us on a quest
to start investigating underground
spaces made by people especially
recently they were intended to last a
very long time and the byproduct of that
is that Alexandra has been to some
peculiar places that almost nobody gets
to go and had thoughts nobody gets to
think because of that and he's here to
talk about them tonight
thanks Stuart and it's uh thank you all
for cramming into our little space here
this is the first time I've given this
talk is kind of a subset of my usual
talk that I've expanded for tonight so
I'd appreciate any feedback on it the
and I hope that it can be in plenty
interactive I guess we're gonna do
questions at the end so please to hold
on to them but if there's if there's
some unbelievably pressing question feel
free to shout it out and we'll try and
answer it right in the middle this is
also the first time I've given a talk
where I'm not explaining what the clock
project is so just show of hands does
everybody here know what the clock
project is actually I need the other one
does anybody not know what the clock
project is we have one person two people
three people okay great okay so I'll
just do the very fast version that we
the long now foundation was started to
foster long term thinking and
responsibility and the one of the ways
of doing that was Danny Hillis his idea
to build an icon to long term thinking a
ten thousand year old mechanical clock
that people could come visit at a remote
site and the whole process of visiting
it and seeing it and talking about that
physical object would embody this
long-term thinking
process and so Stewart said I got hired
fairly early on in the process and since
that time we've been doing research on
this and I'm gonna talk about some of
the places that I've been in some of the
research that I've done and I'm always
interested in more cool places that
exemplify long-term thinking and or
ideas from others so please do bring
them to me the first thing I want to be
clear about is what our scale is our
scale isn't eternity our scale isn't
astronomical time so you know here's
this is roughly if you were looking at
our little spiral arm of the universe
this is the kind of 20 billion year
timescale of astronomic time and we're
not trying to solve problems on that
time scale this is a geologic time scale
this took you know five million years to
create the Grand Canyon this is still a
few orders of magnitude out from where
we're at at ten thousand years this idea
of the long now basically as long as
humans have had modern civilization
since the since the beginning of
Agriculture and later cities and you
know as if you if you think about it in
those terms there's actually there's a
lot of things that have survived on this
time scale and human artifacts and and
I'm just going to talk through at first
why some of those things have lasted and
why some of those things have not lasted
and I'm not all my examples are about
things that have lasted I think we have
we have ample examples of things that
haven't but I do want to go over why
things do deteriorate or get lost and I
broke it down into a few categories
basically water and air combined are
probably the two major things they
destroy buildings they destroy metal
objects they even destroy rock at some
point as that as water gets into it and
freezes in the winter cracks the rock
apart and I'm going to talk a bit about
a specific type of corrosion oxidization
called galvanic corrosion and how we're
working with that and and how we can
look at history at how that's been how
that's fair
it turns out that one of the one of the
ways that things don't last as they get
lost we we know for instance that the
Greek tragedies many of the Greek
tragedies that we have heard reference
to we we don't have and there's a ton of
other things that we don't know if we've
lost right so this is this is one of the
worst worst ways and then you can be
found you can lose things and you can
find them at the wrong time so if for
instance there was many Egyptian
artifacts that were found during the
expansionist era of the of England that
were brought back just as ballast and
dumped in the London Harbor they they're
theoretically still there obelisks and
things like that but that was not a very
good time for Egyptian artifacts to have
been found if they had been found later
they would have been much more prized
and/or things sometimes they get found
at a bad time in their in our ability to
preserve them and so that's a good thing
to avoid and then of course there's just
plain old destruction and the worst
example of this you know is Wars but
also you see we've seen it in the
Buddha's of Bamiyan in Afghanistan which
were destroyed based on ideology that I
mean of the ideologies in the world
Buddhism is a pretty benign one but they
the Taliban still spent many days in
many man hours and a lot of munitions
destroying these giant car it is so
that's probably the one that is the most
kind of unworkable for us on our
timescale I don't know what we can do to
solve that one and we have we have a few
strategies that I'm going to go over and
then there's this other funny one which
is that you just become unfashionable
and this is something that happened here
in San Francisco for instance after all
the beautiful Victorians were built the
50s came around and they were looked at
as old and funky and not modern and they
put up all these beautiful concrete
tilt-up structures that we now have in
you know the last remaining Victorians
we prize but there's this there's this
product problem of the product hype
cycle and many of you have seen this
this is the Gartner hype cycle you know
there's a technology trigger
there's the peak of inflated
expectations as well before the product
gets released and the product gets
released and you know there's the iPad
where the trough of disillusionment when
you don't know what to do with that
thing and then there's the slope of
enlightenment where you know people
start figuring out oh well I can sit on
the couch and I can surf the web and
it's a great thing and then there's the
plateau of productivity when people
really start figuring out all the cool
things they can do with their iPad now
you can look at this as just the iPad
time cycle or you can also look at this
as even cultural artifacts or buildings
in architecture if you just decide that
your time axis is is much further and so
if you do the the long term version of
the hype cycle the the thing that
happens after acceptance and this you
could have a time of utility let's say a
building or a lung or a big culture
artifact this could be a century or more
of acceptance and use but eventually it
declines and then there's going to be
some time where that thing becomes
obsolete or unfashionable and this is
the most dangerous time this is where
things usually get lost and destroyed so
for instance the you know the the casing
stones of the pyramids or at least the
pyramids were looted not too long after
they were they were loaded up with all
the loot and it just takes a few
generations usually one or two
generations after the the people who
built it are gone that the next
generation just doesn't have the values
and the same systems that their parents
did or it's a whole new culture that got
brought in through war or some other
cultural change and they destroy that
thing but then comes this moment like
now where the those Egyptian artifacts
or the pyramids are this priceless
cultural treasure and so how do you how
you bridge this trough of obsolescence I
think is actually one of the largest
challenges that long now faces in in how
we make a ten thousand year object so
I'm going to talk about a few strategies
for that so why why do things last
they're lost and they're found at the
right time the you know as long as you
are as long as it is found again then
then you're okay and you're found at a
time of good preservation sometimes
you're just chemically lucky so
that normally would not make it over the
long term get buried in a particular
type of soil that happens to mummify
remains or something like that and it
just makes it you know the dinosaurs
that died in the lair at La Brea Tar
Pits were the ones that that we can we
were able to pull back out things are
maintained so there's a few things and
there's a few cultures and in both
England and in Japan and other places in
the Far East where they've actually
maintained things on a millennial time
scale and so you can actually build that
of extremely vulnerable materials like
wood and thatch and rice paper and have
those things last for a very long time
and basically an indefinite there's
things that are just made really really
tough and so you know we have pottery
shards from tens of thousands of years
ago and we even have complete pots from
tens of thousands of years ago and
though these types of things can last we
have some metal objects from over 5,000
years ago from the Bronze Age and
another technique is that they just take
a really long time to complete and
that's one way of passing this trough of
obsolescence where if you're a cathedral
for instance that takes 600 years to
finish that the generation that finishes
it is has already it's already
transcended into this cultural icon and
then there's this funny one that that's
an emerging one that I and I don't know
what to do with it but it's this
ablative armor technique and I'm going
to talk a bit more about what that is
and how I've seen it be successful so in
the chemically lucky category we have
things like this this is a five thousand
five hundred year old shoe made of
leather right and so when people ask me
about we know what are you making the
clock of the long now out of its like
how about leather right this is a five
thousand five hundred year old shoe but
this is the only reason this survived is
was found in Armenia and it was buried
in soil conditions that that made it
work so we would either need to provide
we'd need to either need to bury it in
those type of conditions and it would it
would be very difficult to visit
obviously if if it
all under dirt the another another
chemically lucky thing and a thing that
got lost and found at the right time was
the Dead Sea Scrolls and you know these
date back to 150 BC and they're still
with still taking them apart with x-rays
and and finding new information on them
but they were sealed in a jar I believe
a ceramic jar and they made it 2,000
years basically by being lost another
one that just had a good environment
this is a good reason for caves and
being underground is some of the cave
paintings these are some of the more
famous ones from Lascaux these are over
seventeen thousand three hundred years
ago made of pigments mineral pigments
and you know since then they're mineral
pigments are made out of stone the
pigments themselves have survived some
better than others but it's a it's
another good example of the both
chemically lucky and being lost this one
is actually one of the most intriguing
ones to me that and it's a fairly recent
discovery of mine it doesn't really look
like much here but that's that's wood
and lacquer that's over 2,000 years old
and it was found in a in a tomb in China
where the whole thing was plankton cedar
and then encased in white clay and then
encased in six feet of activated
charcoal and then white clay and then
dirt again and it was lost for over
2,000 years and when they did find it or
I guess it was purposely buried for
2,000 years they weren't really
intending for people to find it but when
they did find it the contents were in
such good shape that they were able to
perform an autopsy on the person who was
buried there for instance and get
everything out of their stomach that
cause of death was a heart attack I mean
all the organs everything was was intact
and there's this the activated so they
were sealed from the water with the clay
and then the activated charcoal did this
neat effect and and one can only assume
that they understood what this effect
was or it's called a getter and this is
the same effect that keeps a vacuum in a
vacuum too but or at least originally
did
and that activated charcoal is actually
grabbing the air molecules out of the
air and process chemically bonding with
them and making them not oxygen so this
became effectively an oxygen-free
atmosphere that was preserved with very
very low technology for 2,000 years and
would have gone on indefinitely
basically if it had not been found and
we can presume that there's even more of
these tombs left but this is one of the
few and I point this one out because
this is one of the few ones that
actually I think was intentional or that
they actually put in technology to have
the the remains and the organic matter
lasts so this is you know again wood
that's 2,000 years old not your usual
multi millennial material and then
there's the Bronze Age so we have you
know this was Danny Hillis his original
idea of Bronze Age technology so to
build this clock or at least to maintain
the clock and items that are between
from 3300 BC so 5300 years old have
survived quite intact some better than
others but bronze even and especially
that early bronze is actually not that
metallurgically good yet some of it got
chemically lucky and where it got lost
and stored and we have some of it some
of it not so much but now with more
modern techniques you can certainly
expect modern metals like stainless
certain stainless steels titanium things
like that to last on the order of ten
thousand years in at least a decent
freer environment this is one that
intrigued me and start making me think
more about wood and on our property in
Eastern Nevada we have Bristlecone Pines
and they they're an interesting one and
of themselves they they're a living
object that can live for over 5000 years
and or at least up to 5,000 years in
fact you can see where the rocks have
eroded around their root structure by
like six inches in 3,000 years so the
rocks are eroding faster than the than
the wood there but this beam I was this
I'm about eight stories up in in the
cupola of a Cathedral in Ely England
one of the worst places for a dry
environment and that beam right there
and that whole series of beams is the
railings and stuff are all modern but
the all the main structural elements
holding this thing up are over 700 years
old and still doing just fine as long as
they can keep the water out from the
roof and and then I do a little bit of
research into what the oldest wooden
structure still standing wooden
structure in the world in is and of
course it's it's in Japan and it's it's
this temple from 680 so 1400 years of
constant maintenance so this is this all
these fall into the category of you need
an institution or government or whatever
that maintains things and this one was
clearly well maintained and I'm gonna
bring up another one that was maintained
in a different way and another
maintenance story is the the Vatican we
at one of our library conferences we had
the vice prefect from the Vatican
library here at Stanford and when I went
to Italy he gave me this great tour
behind the scenes of the Vatican Library
walked by this one room that had all
these super flat drawers and I asked
what they were and we went in and we
opened the doors and it looked like this
and it it turns out that when they built
Saint Peter's Basilica
they made the artists do overruns of
every color tile that they had to make
for that for those mosaics and and
apparently to quite a bit of protest for
at least that was the story he told me
that they had to make all these extra
tiles and then they stored them and to
this day they're still maintaining all
of those mosaics 500 years later and
they do quite a bit of it when I was
leaving it they were just closing for
Easter Mass and only 45 minutes after
they closed all these mosaics had
scaffolds up in front of them and there
are little guys and white bunny suits
gluing little tiles and so it's a it's a
pretty active process so it made me
think that actually if you walk around
and look at the ground you might be able
to pick up your own tile at some point
so this is the other Japanese temple
that's maintained in a different way
than the last one the last one was
actually maintained it's the same
structure this is the temple at esa
which was one of the first things on
this project that Stuart
to my attention and this is a very rare
photograph that was taken when both the
temples are erected at the same time but
basically one temple gets deconstructed
and another one gets reconstructed every
20 years so once a generation the master
teaches an apprentice
these are Shinto temples and so it's
it's it's arguable that these kind of
practices have helped Shinto the Shinto
religion make it through the Buddhism
coming across from China and this actual
physical embodiment of their religion
has helped the next one is scheduled to
be finished in 2013
I haven't we're just talking about
whether or not there was any damage from
in that construction from the earthquake
gonna be interesting to find out but
that would be a trip that I would like
to make is to see the commissioning of
this apparently only the Emperor and the
Emperor's family are allowed in however
one of my favorite examples is the
Antikythera device if you've ever heard
of it this is this was turns out this
was an astronomical clock it was lost
off the coast of Antikythera Greece
where it was found and it's it's a
strangely it's the only object like it
that we found and it predates it brings
back the date of when people think we
invented things like differential
gearing and a lot of the knowledge of
the Western world of celestial mechanics
and things like that by over 1500 years
in some cases depending on the
technology you're talking about and with
recent x-ray technology they've been
able to get learn a lot more and these
guys in England and other places have
done full reconstructions and and it
turns out it's a pretty advanced
astronomical device it clearly wasn't a
one-off because people must have built
many prototypes to get to the stage but
no one's ever found anything like it
that dates to that era but it's a great
example for us building a ten thousand
year clock is that even if someone were
to find it and it had been lost for a
long time
that if we build it right and it's this
mechanical thing that they might be able
to reconstruct it if we give the right
signals through the whole design so the
pyramids are a are an example of this
ablative technique that I was going to
talk about and so a blade of armour on
like
on a tank a sacrificial armor on a tank
or a blade of paint on the bottom of a
boat is a type of paint that sheds away
as barnacles stick on to it so this is a
successful method that has been used in
a couple places that I've found and so
the pyramids well you know they they
originally had beautiful casing stones
they were filled with tombs and all
kinds of riches those all those things
were taken away the outer casing stones
were mined to be used in mosques in
Cairo later and the stuff inside was was
was sacked quite soon but the basic
pyramid nough sub them is still there
right so we still have that so if if you
offer some kind of thing to be taken
maybe that is a new way to get something
to last for a long time and another
example this isn't nearly as old of
course these were only the the Taj Mahal
was built in the 1600s mid 16th century
or mid 17th century but it was encrusted
with jewels all the way throughout all
the hallways and the final time the
British sacked it they instead of
burning this place or destroying it like
a lot of other buildings that got
destroyed of the the Imperial time of
India they spent a long time prying all
those jewels out of the walls in fact by
the time they had finished that they
they decided that the cultural artifact
was clearly worth saving it's hard to
know if they would have saved it either
way
but it it again is this ablative
technique of getting things to last for
a really long time and I mentioned
cathedrals this is the one of the oldest
cathedrals and it took 600 years to
build this is in Cologne Germany and
it's still being worked on and we have a
modern example of this the the Sagrada
família and in Barcelona by Gaudi was
started in 1882 it's still under
construction they're hoping to be done
with the next phase sometime around 2026
but that's sounding optimistic right now
already so we will see but it's a it's
already passed that threshold this has
already passed that that trough of
obsolescence and unfashionable threshold
you know I think this thing will be
saved as I think it's our
a unesco object at this point so now we
get into a few examples where people
were really intentional about building a
ten thousand year space or or longer at
least in a multi millennial space and so
this is the this is the exit of one of
the tunnels at Yucca Mountain Yucca
Mountain is now closed as a nuclear
waste site but we'll see how long that
remains I think disasters like the
recent one may change people's minds
about storing spent material on site the
we went and visited this this is uh when
did we visit this Stewart mm okay and
they give us an interesting tour you get
to ride in a little car all the way down
those blue access ramps are basically
the only part of it that's the blue
access ramp up and down is basically the
only thing that's done they haven't dug
any of the repository tunnels to my
knowledge but the idea there is is that
it can be stored and the one of the best
things about this project is that they
did a bunch of great federal research in
how to in ten thousand year materials
both in nickel alloys stainless steels
ceramics glasses all these things and
it's all publicly available as well as
concrete's and I'll mention the concrete
again when we get to our site this is an
interesting one that I I'm hoping to be
my next visit this is uncle Onew clear
waste repository all of the yellow part
is actually already done this was in
Helsinki Finland or outside of Helsinki
Finland and they have designed it with a
hundred thousand year timespan recently
there was a documentary done on this
which I thought was pretty alarmist but
it's a pretty a pretty great engineering
effort and like and like the the one in
in Nevada they're great engineering
solutions and the thing that the two
things that we walked away from there
there's two main lessons one is that you
can't solve a political problem with an
engineering solution
and you know you can enjoy you can only
engineer so many you know nines on the
end of 99.9 percent sure it's gonna be
okay and when you say when you're trying
to make guarantees for ten thousand
years it just doesn't work like you you
there's always a hole in your theory of
your of your ten thousand year theory so
it's actually vastly better to come up
with a series of century theories than
it is to come up with one ten thousand
year theory so the other the other thing
that I'm learning and visiting some of
these sites and seeing these pictures
from on kalo is that they're actually
picking some of the same techniques we
are arched rubes drill and blasting done
in a special way so it cuts from hole to
hole all those lines you see right there
it means that the explosive traveled
from one hole to the next to the next
the next and didn't over break the rock
so that it doesn't last into the future
and doesn't fault doesn't keep falling
in on you so that was that was good to
see that there are engineers came up the
same solution that we did my most recent
trip which I did I guess a little less
than a month ago this is through just
three or four weeks ago was to a site
that was designed to last for 1,000
years and it's in Svalbard it was
interesting I saw the announcement I
think that they were gonna build this
around 2005 and saw a little computer
rendering of it and in 2008 I saw an
announcement that it was done and I was
just so shocked that they could build a
1,000 year seed vault in Svalbard in
such a short time from design to
completion and that's me on the left and
Steve Rowell and the right small bard is
a little island in archipelago about two
hours north by plane of the most
northern part of Norway it's that it's
the northernmost and permanently
inhabited place on the planet you can
get commercial flights into there it's
mostly eyes they're basically subsidized
by the Scandinavian government but they
you can buy a ticket and go and it's
it's mostly a mining place they it's a
coal mining island on your on your
approach
is what it looks like that's small
barred Airport this is probably the best
weather that we had almost the entire
trip right here but it was still blowing
40 miles an hour across the runway I
made for a pretty exciting landing so
they chose a different technique they
were they're trying to store seeds for
all the seed banks in the world and so
instead of going to the high desert in
effect this is a high desert actually
has very low precipitation but it's a
high cold desert instead of a high hot
desert and it's not high I guess it's at
sea level but it's high in in latitude
the the goal here was to find a place
that was naturally cold enough to store
the seeds even if their cooling system
failed they need they they target their
cooling system for the seeds at negative
18 C and the permafrost on Svalbard even
in summer never gets above negative 5 C
so and even at negative 5 C the seeds
can last for 20 or 30 years all on their
own
there's also a funny arrangement of
Svalbard politically that made it made
it more accessible you can kind of build
things there that you wouldn't be able
to build in other places it has this
funny treaty that was signed about 90
years ago that that makes it kind of
politically easy to work in this is the
design of the facility that I saw back
in 2005 and and I'll walk you through it
so this outside bit those are the doors
and there's this kind of light art thing
that shows up up there at night when no
one's really up there to see it but
there's some nice nighttime photos I've
seen published of it and so you go in
the doors and you and you get to this
tube and this tube is apparently a
special technology that was developed on
Svalbard by the coal miners and this was
the other issue thing that I found out
is they tried to build this in 2005 when
it was the peak of the building of the
construction boom and they and I still
to this day haven't found someone to
tell me why they had to have it done by
2008 but that was their goal and so they
couldn't find anyone to bid on the
project at all and so the only people
they would bid on it were that coal
mining companies on Svalbard and so they
had the coal mining companies build it
and that's that the rock and swab art is
just like crumbling schist it just falls
apart
so what they do to get through the
permafrost is they do this thing called
the Svalbard - which is this thing and
it goes through the the most mobile part
of the permafrost which which moves
around a lot
under freeze and thaw conditions and you
can see actually in the right side of
this photo in the left side of the of
the hallway where it's already
corrective already had to do a bunch of
renovations in this and this is a
downward sloping thing which you can see
from here was this is a downward slope
and then it upward slopes at the bottom
of that tube up to the seed vaults just
slightly and this is a lesson that we
learned in other places as well this is
a retrofit these are pumps so what
happens is that the frost builds up on
the inside of these walls then it thaws
and it drops down to the floor and then
it it it runs down towards your seeds
that you can't be destroyed
so the so then they put in these pumps I
had hoped to go here to learn a lot
about engineering a 1,000 year facility
from from their efforts I I wasn't
terribly encouraged by what I saw
except for this login book had
signatures from Jimmy Carter ban ki-moon
delegations from the US Congress all
kinds of people and it made me realize
that even in the most ridiculously
out-of-the-way remote place you can go
in the planet people are going to want
to come see your weird thing and in fact
the more or the harder you make to get
there the more likely they're gonna want
to come see your weird thing and the
weirder it is the more they want to come
and whatnot so once you get through the
doors you get into this this white
concrete which white underground we've
also found in other places this is a
good technique it's just this is called
shotcrete where they shoot concrete over
the over the rock they had to do it only
in winter when it was frozen solid and
the rock wasn't falling in on them this
is the kind of crosswise hallway that
goes to all those three back bank
that you saw in the model this is what
one of the empty rooms look like they've
only filled one of them and and then
looking back across the hallway the
frosty door there on the right is the
one that's that's currently got seeds in
it you can see the frosty pipes going
into it cooling it from negative its
ambient in this room is negative 5c and
going into there it's it's negative 18 C
and they you know basically it's all
relying on the coal plant on the island
as well for that cooling this was a cool
thing that they did is this is what they
turned when they turned on the lights
when you're in there but this is what it
looks like when there's nobody there
this is just the emergency LED lighting
and I thought it was much nicer actually
this is the door going in and this is as
far as we were told that we were ever
going to get actually and but they had
to do they had to go in there and check
on something so we were lucky enough
that they opened the doors and we got to
see a cage with much seasoning but they
had these standard boxes for all the
seeds which you see and then there's the
USDA which sends them cardboard on the
left
of course the USDA decided not to do the
standard box but basically you know I
thought that this place was a reaction
to genetically modified foods where they
were trying to store for this you know
genetically modified Armageddon that was
clearly coming as far as Europe was
concerned but it's not it at all they
they had they had started these seed
vaults long before in fact there's
another seed vault a prototype one
that's in a container and another tunnel
an old an old coal mine in swab art and
they decided to do this largely just as
a backup so they only store replacement
seeds for ones that are already and
other seed banks and they don't they
don't own them the original place still
owns them you can get them back at any
time they're all everything that's on in
the seed bank is a public log so you
know what's there this is what all the
containers were look like that they've
that they've received mostly now it's
all these mylar bags so again this is a
purposeful 1,000 year facility but I
think this one's probably going to take
a lot more maintenance
luckily I think they now have enough
interest from all these different
countries and people that that interest
for maintenance will be continued
another one that was designed with a
1,000 year life that is an interesting
one we learned a lot of lessons from as
well is the Mormon genealogical vault in
it I had been every Mormon that I had
encountered I had asked about this vault
and they all said oh yeah it's there no
no you can't go and and it was it wasn't
until actually Stewart got invited I
think to give a talk at Brigham Young
and I said okay don't say yes wait say
only if we can go see the vault and that
they wouldn't they still wouldn't do it
but they said if you both fly out to
Salt Lake City and have lunch with
Mormon elders we'll decide if you can
see it evolved and so we did and we had
lunch at the top of the Joseph Smith
Memorial Building in in Salt Lake City
with the elders and we ate I think it
was buffalo burgers and deep-fried
pickles and talked about archiving
strategies and long-term thinking and
they decided we were good and they we go
I got to about here before they took
away my camera and but they were really
forthcoming they gave us an excellent
tour and I've since offense they've
released some photos at the inside and I
think they've released a virtual tour
now which I couldn't find but I heard
saw references to but this is a this is
what one of these tunnels you see these
tunnels in the background to this photo
they basically they drilled and blasted
tunnels going straight back a series of
five tunnels and then did some crosswise
tunnels and lined them again with kind
of like the small bar tube this metal
tube and then pumped concrete around it
to stop the water from coming in was the
theory anyway so this is the one that
tunnels were getting drill and blasted I
suppose these are Mormon architects so
this is my little drawing of what this
place kind of an overhead plan view of
what this looks like this front area is
a work area where actually there was a
back 40 people work every day all day
and then they have these series of vault
doors and then you go back and then
there's all the microfilm storage of all
the genealogical records records and in
the way back
they left it unto band they just put a
little dam up and actually the waters
coming naturally through the rock and
they have their own reservoir their own
water supply for the whole for the whole
facility which they use for washing film
as well as just drinking and use their
so most of what the people were doing is
this this isn't so you can see that
metal tube wall here again white
underground there's no there's no
windows here so they have a long work
day and then this is a photo I found of
the vaults so this is what all of those
crosswise tubes look like filled with
and they're a lot a lot of of microfilm
all stored in the order that they were
found and the index is all in an Oracle
database so the thing that we learned
here and they were really nice at the
end of this tour we they took us to a
conference room and they rolled out all
the plans on a table and let us look
through the original blueprints not take
any pictures or anything but they let us
really look through it and see how it
was all made and then they also did a
series of retrofits of of the
underground facility about 20 years in
because it started flooding and this is
the thing that we see with all these
underground facilities that they all try
and keep the water out and they all fail
so they put that they put steel in then
they pumped concrete to seal the steel
but eventually it got to the welds and
then the welds were weld where the
welding was it attracts oxygen then the
then that rusted through and the water
came in and so that the the Mormon
archive is has actually flooded several
times in its existence they they didn't
keep stuff in the bottom drawers because
of that and then they also went in and
they cut channels in the floor and ran
the water out under here they have these
giant nuclear proof vault doors and they
have channels running underneath them
for the water to come out
Hey they realized that water was a more
pressing concern than the then clearly
Russia targeting them as a major
cultural asset so now I'm going to talk
about some of the stuff about our clock
the some of the stuff I'm gonna show is
stuff that we don't show really publicly
and we're under construction right now
and so we're our head is kind of down
working on that and but in in a small
environment I can I can show it all to
you but the the first thing that that we
found out as we started researching how
to get metals to last for a really long
time is this notion of the galvanic
series and so the galvanic series is a
listing of metals by their voltage
potential and so platinum is very high
at would be considered a zero and then
as you go down into things like aluminum
if you've ever seen what a penny a
copper penny sitting on top of a
aluminum boat in salt water does that
penny will go right through it in a few
months
that is galvanic corrosion so basically
you've got dissimilar metals that are
far apart on the on the galvanic series
and then you put an electrolyte of salt
water on it and it burns through and so
we spoke of the law we've we've worked
with a lot of material scientists and
one and finally in one conversation the
guy said everything is burning it's just
a question of how fast and so everything
is subject to this effect and so you
have even in air you can air can be an
electrolyte as lightning proves and so
you you always have this effect if
there's a little bit of salt in the air
then that it's it's even worse but you
want to use things that are very high on
this scale and you want to when you put
them right up against each other if you
do it at all
you want to use things that are very
close on the on that scale if not
identical on that scale so you'll see
that most of the things that we make on
the clock most things in this room in
fact except for the short term
prototypes are all made out of things
like minal three one six stainless
titanium and we're staying out of the
silver on
scale just to make it less of a nuisance
to be stolen this is one of the most
recent parts that we just finished on
the clock this is this is a an 8 or 9
foot diameter gear it uses a special
cycloidal pattern that's actually every
single one of those teeth is three
dimensionally carved and it goes into a
special roller that rolls in such a way
that there's never a moment where
anything scrubbing so the other type of
destruction that can happen to to metals
is that as they rub up against each
other you can get Micro welding or
another effect called galling where it
rubs away a bit of metal and then they
they slowly just kind of just get
destroyed the other way to fix galvanic
corrosion is to isolate things
electrically and I'll pass this around I
need it back though this is a that's a
silicon nitride ceramic ball bearing
that's being used in the clock and this
is a different type this is an aluminum
oxide type of of ceramic ball bearing
but this is what turns that big gear
that you just saw these are in fact they
we just mounted it up last week on these
bearings but as you can see the two
types of metals we're using an a 286
stainless a hard shaft and we're using a
three one six stainless outside even
though they're very close in the
galvanic scale if we can separate them
with this isolator then they don't cause
a thing they don't cause that galvanic
corrosion the other thing that happens
with bearings is that when they sit and
you have point load the metal as they
sit there and they just micro weld from
small from small vibrations and if if
it's not metal they can't weld or it
can't and it can't gall and so we've
been testing these ceramic bearings with
no lubrication now passing four million
cycles we can't test them very fast
because they build up heat and they
can't shed it but none of our things
move very fast but we had hoped that we
could do very fast accelerated aging or
accelerated tests but we could it's
still it's taken us several months just
to get four million cycles we think some
of the fastest parts of the clock
basically
get to six million cycles so far these
bearings look like they're gonna make it
that big gear that I showed you goes in
this mechanism this is the power system
for the clock so there's those big gears
right there there's three of them and
they're the main differentials for
winding the the clock that underneath
there that big cylinder is a weight
that's hanging from this kind of spine
like rack gear that goes up through the
center and as you walk around that
capstan you're winding that weight up to
the top and most of this is now under
construction most of it being built up
in Seattle I just shot this picture
today at the assembly shop all the parts
are being is some being machined in
different shops and then coming to
coming to our shop in San Rafael that's
Chris ray on the lead machinist he's
been on the project basically as long as
I have I tired him I think in 97 and he
belts pretty much all the things in this
room and the first prototype in the
science museum and again this is so the
ball that I'm passing around is the
silicon nitride carbon silicon nitride
ceramic ball that that is the bearing
for one of the ball bearings for this
device which is the full-scale Geneva
and if you get a chance there's the
chime generator around the corner that's
the part of the clock that can ring a
series of ten bells in a different
sequence each day for 10,000 years so
the the most revolutions one of these
things would go around is four million
cycles so all of these things are well
within the realm of normal tested
products but it's rare that nobody ever
tests them this slow basically or with
no lubrication so we've had to do some
of our own testing to discover that and
the the new lubrication thing is that
lubrication attracts dirt and event and
basically you can't rely on lubrication
always being there because it it goes
away actually have a really complex
thing to do underground in rock and it
turned out that nobody there was no
technology to do this you can drill and
blast and it's really rough you can use
quarrying techniques but it's really
slow
and but there's been recent developments
in querying and so this is Carrara Italy
that's a road there it's like huge
trucks can go on it this is in similar
it's marbleized limestone and in the
last basically ten years they've
developed diamond saw technology that
can cut through stone basically faster
than you would normally associate
cutting through wood and what nobody has
done however they made these saws these
gallery saws which cut spaces like this
that are on hydraulics and they just do
one cut and they reset them up to do
another cut but what nobody has done is
has roboticized this whole thing and I
have a background in the in building
robots for the BattleBots competition so
it was it was fun to finally have a
combination of my long now background in
my BattleBots background into building a
a nine-foot diamond chainsaw that can
cut stone this was built by by Stuart
Kendall of Seattle solstice they made
the base of the ori which you should
check out underneath there and we've
just been doing more tests with it in
just three days ago I was up there now
it's got all the new cuoco robotics
controls and it's actually cutting three
dimensional curves and the idea is that
it's going to be able to do this for us
in that vertical tunnel and then you
break away each layer in between your
cut and you get this kind of smooth
rough smooth rough finish and you do
that for about a year and you get a
spiral staircase in solid rock with no
over break so that's that's what we're
heading towards right now
that's kind of what a guy would look
like on it it'll have a big cart it's
actually gonna be a lot it's gonna be a
kind of a two-story cart really so what
have we learned we learned that we
should make it remote enough that you're
not near a city that gets bombed we have
learned that water is going to get in we
have to we have to route water away from
it the you know even the even the design
of those stairs we design droop into
that saw so that as it's cutting any
water that comes down the walls gets
onto those stairs and then runs away and
then down the outside spiral of the
stairs and all the way down so and all
the entrances that you see those tunnels
that we're making are slightly uphill
all the other ones from up go down and
so the whole thing drains always outward
so we assume that water will get in our
goal is to keep it away from the clock
mechanism and then let it run out
oxidation control so things like
encasing really delicate things so the
escapement and the pendulum are going to
be encased in in glass basically a very
thick quartz glass and use metals that
are high in the galvanic avoid welding
for that reason that we talked about in
the the tunnels at the Morman area we
are using welding we couldn't avoid it
in some places but what we do is we kind
of slot the metal together first so it's
kind of puzzle piece together so even if
the welds fail it's mechanically can't
push through itself and then we
passivate those welds by dipping the
whole thing in acid you get all that
free oxygen off the surface and so
there's there's some techniques you can
use welding for design it to be lost so
a lot of the clock mechanism is
basically designed to even if no one's
there and it doesn't get wound and the
clock stops and the dials aren't moving
that when you find it you'd be able to
figure out how to make it work and wind
it back up and get it all back up to
that to the right time and so things
like that or are a good example of that
where one of the dials of the clock
some of the dials of clock are showing
natural cycles of time so that you can
look at the sky look at this thing
that's broken and rectified the to make
it difficult to disassemble and take it
out of there so this is we're basically
going to build this thing as a ship in a
bottle it's going to have two ends to it
and it's all going to be encased once
it's done and then to and everything's
going to get built in a way that you'd
have to basically just assemble the
whole thing to get it out of there
it doesn't stop somebody who's trying to
mine it for the metals but hopefully it
will it'll slow them down long enough
that we can cross that that chasm of of
unfashionable 'ti the other thing is to
use more ceramics and we're trying to
find ways to use more ceramics things
like the bells we're looking at using
ceramics and one of the first things is
always pillaged out of the European
churches is the big bronze bells to be
melted down for Wars so ceramic bells
are great and it's just the bells are so
easy to steal they're always hanging
from something that can you know it's
like little teeny hinge and you just cut
it loose and there it goes right so but
ceramics are kind of worthless in and of
themselves they can't be remade into
other things really the casings on the
outside of the pyramids were certainly
carved recarved but you know a tube of
ceramic would be a bit harder to do so
it's it's using materials as smart as
you can like that the other one is to
design the long-term institution and
we're still trying to figure that one
out that's that's the law that's the
long now foundation and you know it's
certainly gonna be the technique that's
used at places like that's fall bard
seed bank it's gonna need that kind of
institution surviving alongside it and
this ablative layer one is the one that
we don't know what we're gonna do with
yet but you know should we should we in
case the the you know the the tunnel
with jewels or gold or something that
people will steal and think that they
have taken the value from this thing I
don't know but thank you that's all
we've learned so far
[Applause]
you